- [Kelly] Was it weird when
they asked you to play yourself?
Because it's an exaggerated version
of yourself.
- Very strange.
- Yeah.
- It was the most
daunting thing I've ever done.
Because I --
- When you first read it,
were you into it?
- No.
I was like, no muscle in my body tells me
to make this movie.
I like to hide behind a character.
But this character's name is Nick Cage.
I mean, what are you guys gonna do
to me?
- Dude!
- There's other Cages running around.
I don't wanna humiliate them.
I don't wanna humiliate myself.
- Yeah.
- And I was worried.
- You didn't it. It's brilliant!
- [Nicolas] Well, thank you.
But I thought it might lapse until like
in Andy Sandberg Saturday
Night Live sketch
or something.
- No.
- Thankfully, I had a good director
and he kept it about people.
So that was --
- A great director.
- [Nicolas] Thank you.
- And it's like.
(audience clapping)
It's amazing how the story unfolds.
And like, you don't see some stuff coming.
The LSD trip in the car.
- Oh my gosh!
(both laughing)
- It's like, amazing. (laughs)
- It's funny.
- Like how you look at him
and how Pascal looks like.
- Yeah.
He's so good.
- Pedro Pascal.
Yeah. It was amazing.
- Yeah.
- You two.
Your chemistry,
it's amazing!
- Thank you.
- Like I love when you get like,
starts together that you didn't,
I don't know, I didn't picture it.
And then you're, and it's like
the most amazing chemistry.
- [Nicolas] Well, thank you.
Now. He is not only a great actor,
he's such a nice man.
And it's easy to work with Pedro.
You know, it was kind of like
we had similar interests.
We love movies and we would
just talk about movies.
Kind of like the way
you and I are talking,
and then the director says, "Action".
- That's kinda like
what your characters do.
- [Nicolas] Yeah.
Just talking about movies.
And then we would say action,
and we just kept the conversation going.
- [Kelly] Wait, speaking of action.
That's my favorite part. (laughs)
There's a part in the film
where he's out. (laughs)
Cause he got drunk.
- Oh right.
- And they're trying to
wake him up. (laughs)
- [Nicolas] Yeah.
- And they say, "Action",
and he just springs up. (laughs)
- [Nicolas] That was great.
That was funny.
That was Tiffany.
Tiffany did that.
Action!
- Tiffany.
Tiffany Haddish is it?
- It's so fun.
- It's amazing.
The cast is incredible,
but it's so amazing and narcissistic.
- [Nicolas] Yes.
- Like the whole.
It's just like action and go.
And it's like,
it's so perfectly, like humorous perfect.
- Thank you.
- It's really, really good.
So you also play a young version
of yourself.
- Yeah.
- Which is another great part.
- Yes.
- Cause you,
you make out with yourself.
- Yes.
(all laughing)
Well that's wasn't
in the script.
- It's the most narcissistic.
It wasn't in the script?
- No, no.
I put that in, because
that's what it felt like.
- I love you!
I love you!
(audience clapping)
You put that in the script.
There's this part.
I don't wanna ruin the whole movie.
There is so many great moments.
- Let them.
- But it's like,
there's this moment
you're admiring yourself,
and you're just like, yeah!
- It's like --
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- Well yeah, that
character's name is Nicki.
He's the younger version
of so called Nick Cage.
And I based that character.
- He's super narcissistic.
- So arrogant. So
irreverent, so obnoxious.
And I based him on my
when I was on the Wogan Show in England.
I went on that show,
and I was promoting Wild at Heart.
I did front hand springs,
and I was doing karate kicks,
and throwing money in the audience.
The guy was awful.
I was awful.
I took my t-shirt off,
put a leather jacket on.
I go, "That's who I want to be
in the massive talent movie
to be picking on Nick Cage".
- [Kelly] It was amazing.
- But what happened was I said, okay.
Well, this whole
experience for me is weird
and uncomfortable and awkward.
Kind of like if I were
making out with myself,
and I thought yeah, Nicki
should French kiss Nick.
And, so that's where that came from.
- [Kelly] Me on my couch.
I was like, what?
I literally, I died laughing,
cause then your reaction after is --
- Right.
- Brilliant. (laughs)
- Nick Cage smooches good!
You tell 'em.
- [Kelly] You tell everyone.
(all laughing)
It's amazing (laughs)
Nick Cage, everybody!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] You all have
got to see this movie.
It's called The Unbearable
Weight of Massive Talent.
It's incredible.
It's in theaters everywhere now.
Go see it.